the pursuit of the authentic self you're
in a space in your life and you have
aspirations to be this other person or
you have a broader imagination of what
your life could be like but you don't
know how to get from here to there I
think it's about really connecting with
the truth of who you are and living as
Integris with that as possible and when
you do that I think the universe sees
that and pays attention and little
little sort of bricks on the path are
are put in front of you to gently nudge
you in one direction or the other and if
you are
in a place where you have the presence
of mind the awareness to see that and
heed that then that process compounds
upon itself the more you honor that the
more likely you are to
find evidence in the world to support
that yeah you're only true north is that
voice within yourself that you either
choose to honor or you repress